[Música]
cada elección me parece que las
autoridades electorales lo repiten lo
dicen lo repiten los jóvenes no están
implicados en política a los jóvenes no
les interesan ni ser candidatos ni
participar como lectores no se implican
suficiente el poder que tendrían los
jóvenes de cambiar las cosas a través de
su voto a través de sus candidaturas
podría ser enorme pero siempre nos dicen
que no se implican suficientes horitas
de vido cuando las manifestaciones de
los estudiantes la cantidad inicial ya
en 2012 fue eso fue extraordinario pero
igualmente después de eso tampoco se
reconoce una participación juvenil o
ciudadana en políticas de hecho muchos
los muchos jóvenes creen que no es a
través de la política política que los
cambios van a llegar en las sociedades
pero hoy les presentamos aquí en el
estudio a una excepción que confirma la
regla
alejandra zaga méndez bienvenida que
nada en las américas café como le va
muchas gracias por la invitación muy
bien usted es candidata por el partido
que beck salida en la
circunscripción burguesa sube de
montreal en las elecciones provinciales
de que ve que tendrán lugar en octubre
próximo
alejandra ustedes ustedes candidata de
esa circunscripción que representa una
de las más pobres del canadá como se
explica esta realidad de montreal norte
en particular que es el nombre que le
damos más conocido a esta misma
circunscripción electoral exacto el
mismo los electores de montreal norte
cuando les digo que que la que esta
circunscripción se llama bocazas sobre
no sé si has de reconocer reconoce y
encima de marjal no es un lugar muy
particular aquí en quebec porque no
solamente es un lugar con una gran alta
tasa de pobreza y desempleo pero también
es un barrio en que mucha población
inmigrante yo crecí en montreal norte
mantra el norte es como me dio mi barrio
de acogida es ahí donde aprendí lo que
es el quebec ahí aprendí el francés y
como explicamos esta desigualdad social
bueno no hay que mentirnos en los
últimos años ha habido muchas políticas
que en lugar de sostener y dar un apoyo
a las comunidades inmigrantes las
comunidades pobres han cortado los
recursos en educación en salud y en
servicios sociales y lo que hemos visto
es que entre el 2006 y el 2011 este
abismo en que se está creando entre
montreal norte y resto de quebec ha
aumentado ahí hay un abismo de 15 mil
dólares que falta anual manualmente en
en fort familia en los ingresos de las
familias es enorme mismo 42 por ciento
de los trabajadores en su ingreso
personal que ganan menos de 20 mil
dólares al año eso es lo que llamamos
estar en una situación de pobreza y en
canadá es ese es el límite la pobreza el
20 mil dólares anual entonces es un
lugar con muchos desafíos y creo que son
esos desafíos que a mí me me motiva al
hacer política justamente le va a
preguntar qué es lo que se propondría
como candidata viendo el panorama que
montreal norte
en este momento qué es lo que usted
propone qué es lo que su partido propone
para lugares como esa región de montreal
porque no es el único lugar en donde
nombres en la región de monte el nil
en mí en quebec en general general que
es lo que propone este exactamente las
propuestas de quebec solidaire están muy
con seis se encuentran raíz en esos
problemas sociales en una las de las
luchas más grandes que he llevado como
en el partido y ahora como ha sido
aceptado en la provincia de ontario y la
necesidad s surge porque nos damos
cuenta que cuando gana 12 dólares ahora
no vive sobrevive y che y nos está
pidiendo
un sueldo mínimo de 30 horas equiparar y
que uno pueda tener los oficiales
exactos lo suficiente y lo mínimo
estamos hablando de lo mínimo y ahora en
el 2018 para que una familia pueda
mantenerse a otra cosa que yo veo en
este barrio es que hay muchas familias
monoparentales con solamente que existe
madres solteras y una madre soltera gana
12 dólares la hora
y tiene dos hijos es imposible estamos
condenando a gente a la pobreza entonces
no yo he trabajado mucho con
asociaciones de trabajadores suelto
inmigrantes trabajadores que no están
sindicalizados para lograr esta alza de
15 horas la hora somos el único partido
que hemos llevado esta proposición hasta
la asamblea nacional el año pasado con
un proyecto de ley para reformar la
forma que votamos el salario mínimo no
hemos tenido respuesta pero seguimos en
la lucha ahora lo que hay que mencionar
es que 15 dólares la hora para la gente
que nos está escuchando en américa
latina' le puede parecer una fortuna
porque en ningún país de américa latina
ninguna pero bueno algunos trabajadores
sí pero no son digamos la mayoría de los
trabajadores pueden imaginarse una vida
en la que sean pagados 15 dólares la
hora pero en canadá con los precios de
la comida con los precios de las de las
residencias con los precios en general
de transporte públicas y de proporción
es proporcional entonces es un es un
salario que además ha sido reconocido en
otras provincias con un particularmente
en ontario como lo mínimo para vivir
bien y no caer en la pobreza como el
tema del piso de los 20 mil nueve
los que ella hablaba hace unos instantes
y cuando uno dice veinte mil dólares en
algunos países eso puede sonar a mucho
dinero pero tomando en cuenta la
realidad económica de canadá y de quebec
veinte mil dólares no es prácticamente
nada alguien que gana 20 incluso 25 mil
dólares no sé si no es es el piso
salarial es de 22 mil dólares para la
pobreza bueno muy pobres y ganan menos
de 22 mil dólares un salario que en
otras latitudes sería bueno aquí es
apenas la base o el básico mejor dicho
que no alcanza ni siquiera a cubrir
gastos que pueden ser por ejemplo gastos
particulares especiales de salud de
medicinas y hablando de salud es una
otra la segunda propuesta en la cual
estamos trabajando es el seguro dental
el seguro dental porque es una necesidad
hay que entender que en quebec el seguro
dental es privado bueno si quiere ir al
al dentista tienen que tener un seguro
privado y lo que vemos es que yo veo
familias sobre todo latinoamericanas que
me dicen que les sale más barato por
tomarse un avión ir a su país de origen
a curarse su dentadura
de ofrecernos aquí un seguro público y
es la segunda propuesta que vemos que es
una necesidad no es un lujo curarse una
caries y lo que estamos viendo es que la
repartición la riqueza pasa ahí pasa
dándonos según un seguro de salud que
cubre ampliamente todas nuestras
necesidades ofrecer a los niños hasta
los 18 años un seguro gratis de
prevención y de curación
a las personas adultas cubrir entre 60 y
80% cuando se habla de los costos de la
salud dental en américa del norte en
general por supuesto en eeuu son mucho
más altos que activos aquí también son
al alza los gobiernos los profesionales
de la salud los odontólogos y todos los
profesionales ligados en la salud dental
dicen que los costos para ellos también
son altísimos entonces es realista
plantear una cobertura generalizada como
la que nos propone es tomando en cuenta
que esos costos sanitarios
la actividad dental aquí en américa del
norte son mucho más elevados que en otra
parte estamos en condiciones de cubrir
sus costos nosotros creemos que sí
porque hemos empezado
a tener reuniones con todas las
asociaciones de higienistas las personas
que se encargan de hacer una prevención
y una de las cosas que vemos es que los
costos son muy altos para los fondos y
los dentistas porque ellos absolutamente
un higienista tiene que trabajar con un
dentista al mismo tiempo una de las
cosas que proponemos es dar a los
técnicos en higiene dental una autonomía
como las enfermeras para que puedan
hacer más trabajo preventivo cuando
hacemos más trabajo preventivo no
llegamos a una a un problema más grande
que sea una infección bucal del otro
lado eso baja los costos y del otro lado
el segundo presunto defecto que tiene es
que podemos regular una tarifa para todo
el mundo igual porque si no se cree una
competencia entre los dentistas entre
ellos hubo hablé ser como una vez se
extraen alta cosa de baja base y el
tercer efecto es que aumenta la demanda
ahora hay mucha gente que no van al
dentista porque no tiene dinero ni
cobertura exacta no tiene cobertura no
tiene recursos para pagarlo entonces no
podemos el dentista no recibe esos
beneficios hay una persona sobre 4
a 25 que no pone un pie en una dentista
al año estos 25 por ciento de nuestro
problema yo conozco un caso hace muchos
años atrás cuando todavía ha llegado que
estuve en el bienestar social y hay una
persona que estaba en la ministra social
y se había quedado más del tiempo que le
correspondía porque a partir de los creo
que eran dos años o tres años de estar
bajo el sistema de donde la revista
social uno recibir la atención bucal y
él tenía que arreglarse los dientes y
tenía la posibilidad sería trabajar y no
quería hacerlo porque en él la
posibilidad trabajar de laboral ya no le
brindaba seguro entonces ni siquiera
trabajando a tiempo completo con un buen
sueldo podía pagarse el arreglo de su
boca entonces espero para poder hacerse
tratar el tratamiento grande digamos lo
hizo bajo el viento social
aprovechándose del sistema para poder
salida es un incentivo que queremos lo
que queremos que la gente trabaje en las
buenas condiciones de trabajo porque es
la única forma que
cómo funciona el sistema aquí es que
cuando otros trabajamos pagamos nuestros
impuestos y esos impuestos tiene que ser
redistribuidos en servicio es contribuir
a la sociedad trabajando pero eso quiere
decir que la sociedad también
por supuesto y lo que están cuya
mentalidad un poco peleada con
idiosincrasia en américa del norte
claro pero eso es los valores y es parte
de la visión política y social que
defendemos el xxi solamente quería
aclarar por un paloma un segundo
solamente es cuando hablamos del
problema de acceso a la salud dental no
estamos hablando de pobres solamente
mucha gente mayor conozco gente queremos
el agua porque voy a las todas las
puertas y gente que tiene un salario un
buen salario pero me dice pago 3 mil
dólares la semana a la semana pasada
para que tres mil dólares porque me
faltaba falta un diente es actualmente
ahora una cosa que es criticada con su
partido particularmente recibe críticas
con frecuencia por ser considerado como
un partido idealista un partido de
soñadores ayer particularmente lo
criticaron por haber propuesto un
ambicioso
y bastante caro proyecto de un sistema
de transporte público para toda la
región metropolitana de montreal que le
responden ustedes a la gente que le
responde usted particularmente alejandra
a la gente que le dice no es posible
imaginarse ese tipo de proyectos que son
tan caros para la sociedad son demasiado
grandes demasiado caros y son idealistas
que les responde usted primero que para
hacer política hay que tener ambición y
estamos en una sociedad que
lamentablemente está frente a un muro y
que nuestras generaciones que vienen van
a pagar un precio muy alto por los
cambios con los cambios climáticos y con
los problemas ambientales pues tener una
ambición ambiental de decir tenemos que
darnos un sistema de transporte público
apto al siglo 21 para nosotros no ser
realistas es ser responsables porque si
nos comparamos a otras metrópolis en
europa estamos a años luz de de dar un
servicio el ejemplo lo conozco en contra
del norte no tenemos un metro tenemos
que tomar un autobús de 30 a 40 minutos
a un metro y de ahí otros treinta
minutos más para ir al centro
esas dos horas diarias en la vida de un
trabajador que pasan en un tren el
tráfico en un transporte que no es
eficiente esos manuales va bien dos
horas porque a veces es como una hora y
media una de nueve y a correr al regreso
y si a veces cuando la casa se está
cayendo porque nuestro planeta se está
cayendo tenemos que invertir y en un
momento dado invertir ahora más va a ser
que los costos a largo tiempo para ser
menos si yo tengo el caso para mí yo
viaje y zoom
tres meses de estudio en madrid en el
año 1997
si usted es el 97 fui a hacer un curso
en madrid y me traje de recuerdo el plan
del metro de madrid que en ese momento
tenía 10 líneas un amigo mío volvió de
madrid hace 6 meses me mostró el plan de
metro y tienen 8 líneas más tienen 18
líneas ahora y pasaron 20 años desde el
año 67 hasta hoy cuántas líneas más de
metro ahí en montreal 0 creo que ha
habido cuatro nuevas en la zona del
norte de exactamente y bueno yo también
tuve la oportunidad de ser en berlín el
año pasado y me quedé sorprendida a qué
punto dan una oportunidad de transporte
colectivo transporte activo o un
transporte individual y eso es lo que
nosotros proponemos dar una opción y si
nos va a costar dinero y si cuando llega
y dice oh a mí ya realidad va a cambiar
tanto nos da miedo entonces en ese
momento nos acusan de tiene muchos mucha
ambición
miedo de que el estado de quebec se
endeude y no quiere que las no quieren
que el estado esté entregado por
proyectos ambiciosos que cuestan canel
en el caso del proyecto del sistema de
transporte público para montreal es 25
mil millones de dólares que costaría si
es mucho dinero es mucho dinero no le
puedo decir lo contrario y lo que si no
regresa un poco en los años 60 cuando
hablamos de hydro québec o cuando
hablamos del metro de montreal las
críticas eran las mismas y 50 años
después que vemos vemos los resultados
de tener un transporte público porque
montreal y ha sido muy envidiado en los
años 70 por su transporte público en
norteamérica pero lamentablemente no
llegó a una evolución y por tener por
ejemplo en el caso hydro québec una
compañía estatal que ofrece en
electricidad así que yo creo que debemos
lanzarnos en esta aventura y además hay
que decirlo quienes critican esta
propuesta de inversión en el caso de tu
partido pero hablo en general no lo
estoy haciendo con entidades reguladas
mucho menos no lo además lo que nos
toman en cuenta es cuáles son los costos
los que demanda las demoras que un
habitante de esta ciudad debe vivir
todos los días cuando se sube a un
autobús que tarda 40 minutos en hacer un
trayecto que debería demorarse 10
minutos cuando el metro todos los días
presenta problemas de funcionamiento o
algo subirse a un auto para cruzar uno
de los puentes que une montreal con la
ribera norte de la ribera solo implica
estar 50 minutos parados sin avanzar
gastando combustible malgastando se
adelantaron a exactamente entonces esa
gente no toma en cuenta que eso también
es un gasto y no solamente es un gasto
sino que es un gasto que no suma
absolutamente nada cuando se habla de
propuestas de inversión en
infraestructura quienes critican no
toman en cuenta que esta ciudad y esta
sociedad hace décadas décadas abandonó
la noción de progreso material ya que es
lo que se refiere a inversión en
infraestructura y no hay ciudad que
pueda existir ni mantener su salud si no
invierte en infraestructura louis
presidentes
el miércoles pasado es lamentablemente
un accidente cancelaron seis viajes de
del tren que va hacia el oeste la es la
que es digamos fundan el corazón del
transporte es el oeste de la isla y yo
tuve que viajar dos horas para llegar
también a buscar mi aunque las opciones
nos obras porque nos sobran exactamente
y sobre todo que las periferias no están
conectadas tenemos que pasar por un
centro para ir a la de al lado que
normalmente en 20 minutos esas 22 horas
debían tomar 20 minutos y bueno podemos
creo que muchas personas tienen esta
necesidad nosotros lo único que estamos
en desarticular articular la perdón
cuando un proyecto infraestructura y que
no lo hemos sacado en nuestra cabeza
hemos ido a ver toda la sociedad de
transporte que reciben desde décadas
demandas proyectos aquí y lo que
queremos es poner todo eso juntos y ver
cuál
la solución y que le podemos proponer a
toda la gente de montreal ahora usted no
es la única joven en la en la región en
esa circunscripción hay otra candidata
el july sin ley de aceite seguir perdón
de la coalición a venir que ver que
sería la coalición por el futuro de
quebec y vamos a estar conversando con
ella la próxima semana para ver qué
piensa de estas mismas realidades de las
que usted está hablando en esa región
particularmente pero que tocan a toda la
región de montreal ahora sí entonces
estamos comprobando con usted y con
julie que la juventud se está implicando
particularmente en esas regiones de
montalt ellas de origen haitiano también
entonces representa bien digamos la la
zona porque justamente hay muchos
latinoamericanos hay muchos haitianos en
esa en esa circunscripción de montreal
norte y entonces la juventud está
implicada por lo menos allí usted
recuerda a nuestros oyentes es candidata
por el partido que becks sólida en la
circunscripción burguesa sube de
montreal
alejandra zaga méndez también es
estudiante de doctorado en desarrollo
sostenible licenciada en ciencias
agrícolas
por la universidad mcgill de montreal y
maestro en ciencias de los recursos
naturales en gestión de recursos en
gestión de recursos naturales alejandra
saga méndez mes muchas gracias y decir
merci muchas gracias por venir a
nuestros estudios muchas gracias por el
tiempo y la interés que tienen en mi
candidatura hasta una próxima vez en
unos sistemas gracias